okay and welcome to this video playing
Thomas Tallis yeah I think he plays the
IE place those Queens pawn queen porn
openings yeah add this against him a
number of times maybe I can take with
the pawn for a change and trying to
exploit my bishop eddie long term c 5 or
not c5 c3 not sure yeah good i'm getting
getting a bit of space there maybe c3
queen bee six queen bee three this kind
of thing
yeah position is very rigid not sure
okay but let's let's do it okay it's not
raining
yeah I've an h-file I want to have g5 I
move that I really don't know what to do
against does that be 32 I just take
their maybe
probably have to take now trying to do
something on the C file in fig OC for he
also weakens them sell a bit so yeah
probably I'm just castling then rook c7
things like that an interesting idea for
him is to try to exploit my light square
something like yeah I know like h5 g5
takes is six and then g4 or something
which is a bit crazy but interesting
okay close them yeah I wonder if I
should play a five but I don't think
it's it's really great idea tolling on
the C file should be good if he goes
before I have a five so that's not a
good idea at all before just weakens
wide maybe had Knight a5 actually write
a 50 BTW has returned a simple move like
rugby one so let's start with doubling
here on the c4 at least I was quick here
Queen a3 is some surprising thought
bishop fa does something that I'm
intended to do anyway maybe you can take
and play no we cannot play with the six
I have night 64 that's good didn't see
that one in beforehand though ok so I
have queen before now if I like
shouldn't be too bad but
anything better it looks a bit shaky
what is doing I understand that my
position also has its problems but the
diagonal and so on looks a bit shaky I
wonder night before is also john cabot's
let's do this
so just moving the king I am maybe um
maybe
can you choose may be possible i takes
afford I know that doesn't look like a
great idea now he has to move has to
take King King Rufus ridiculous a taxi
form can you have one maybe okay I
thought be six now just checking the
whole structure with chicks I probably
just recapture and b6 Roxy one is
leading nowhere can you to simply
maybe I could have played loop c5
actually using this is pinned app yeah
I'm in a bit a bit of a very quick mode
here and kind of tempted to play quickly
because he spent so much time to be
honest yeah the check he had kingi to
that didn't really lead to anywhere I am
maybe take roxie three trying to win the
pond i guess i will win the pond hmm
yeah so check check it and now yeah the
thing is Luke p 896 rugby 798 hmm
awkward
hmm
ok so do I have no way to keep the pawn
that's kind of bad oh my god ok so let's
see what I can do here this has really
gone this pawn I really hate that I have
no way to keep it I think
maybe he and then g5 to get get activity
so maybe you can reroute this this
Bishop somehow to e4 would be great here
and then like here and bishops somewhere
around time morning do I get this
activated to e4 would be ideal he gets
to see 5 hmm hmm thats probably solid
enough what he has him
yeah cannot win this to two bishops it
doesn't help doesn't help probably I
cannot win I mean I will try okay okay
we have very little time only now saw
that really probably it's it wrong I
can't get the bishop to e4 so this is
there this is no life for ya ever
winning on time but it's not really a
position where you can just give him a
draw I can go f6 Bishop to e4 maybe run
the King around don't know maybe a draw
very likely a draw but not sure the
bishop only four is really strong yeah
difficult it looked nice there with the
bishops but i don't know like here here
yeah could it could have taken on c5
this b6 was really really a bit a bit
quick yeah i could have taken the comp
just says this and it takes a seven next
two okay then it's not even even that
brilliant yeah this is nice but he sees
super solid and kami just wins this pawn
back yeah i mean i was trying but
probably the structure is very very
sound for white probably a draw it even
at the end there you can still try on
with those some with those bishops and
the bishop coming to you for I know very
high draw probability but I have to try
okay well thanks for watching